Hatta is my truest friend he's in need I
will help him it will be a race against
time time is a heat
well actually time was Lewis Carroll's
idea in the first book Alice in
Wonderland Mad Hatter says Alice I'm
stuck at his Tea Party because time and
I quote this time last year or last
March and I thought that's a brilliant
idea for a character there's no real
reference to what his character is so
the challenge was to create a character
that could fit into that world because
their characters have been around for
more than a century Alice wants to go
back in time to save the Hatter's family
and also to save the Hatter but she
wants to steal the chronosphere and in
order to do that she has to kind of
confront time himself who's as the
director James puts it a confident kind
of idiot and I thought I know no one
better the photic on for the video than
my friend Sasha Baron Cohen and so I
invited him to come
do you know playing the character and he
does a brilliant job Sasha brilliantly
plays you know very confident buffoons
so they're dynamic is very funny because
she's the only one who kind of calls him
out on his you know ridiculousness you
know what good have many many years and
so we came up with this idea of this
sort of quasi German mid-atlantic voice
you cannot escape lust ridiculous outfit
he's a man who believes and impressing
people from the outset even though he's
been much too beautiful press about and
so he has his ridiculous hat and
enormous shoulders and he's very
over-the-top but really is a little boy
in the giant man's costume Lewis Carroll
obviously is an utter genius it was
amazing to think that he really catches
a hundred years ago and where today
still talking about in this room it's a
pretty incredible achievement of his
young lady your time is up